aquí está otro derivado del ácido
carbónico este de la derecha es un
anhídrido de ácido y podemos formarlo a
partir de ácidos carboxílicos si
empezamos con el ácido carboxílicos y en
el primer paso añadimos una base como
hidróxido de sodio y en el segundo paso
añadimos cloruro de asilo entonces
formamos nuestro anhídrido de ácido como
producto
y si pensamos en el mecanismo el
hidróxido de sodio es una base elaño en
hidróxido tomará este protón dejando a
estos electrones atrás en el oxígeno y
ya hay dos pares libres de electrones en
el oxígeno para empezar
continuaré dibujando el producto
formaremos 'la unión' carboxilasa este
oxígeno aquí abajo tendrá tres pares
libres de electrones en el de esta
manera y si seguimos algunos de esos
electrones tenemos una carga formal de
menos 1
y si resaltamos estos electrones en
magenta esos electrones vinieron al
oxígeno para formar nuestro añón
carboxilasa y eso funcionará como
nuestro núcleo pilot en el segundo paso
añadimos nuestro cloruro de asilo
continuamos dibujando nuestro cloruro de
ácido
este será nuestro electro filo y
pensamos porque tenemos al oxígeno
quitando densidad electrónica de este
carbono porque el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono tenemos esto
y luego también tenemos a este cloro
haciendo lo mismo
el cloro es más electro negativo que el
carbono también entonces tenemos a estos
dos quitando densidad electrónica
y entonces este carbono de aquí es
definitivamente electro físico y
entonces tenemos nuestro núcleo fino que
atacará a nuestro electro frío nuestro
núcleo fi lo ataca nuestro electro filo
estos electrones se van al oxígeno y
podemos continuar mostrando el resultado
de nuestro ataque núcleo físico ahora
tendremos a este carbono doblemente
enlazado a este oxígeno y luego este
oxígeno ahora está enlazado a este
carbono y luego tenemos un oxígeno aquí
con tres pares libres de electrones y
una carga formal de menos 1 aún tenemos
a este carbono enlazado a un cloro y aún
tenemos un grupo r prima aquí así
así que siguiendo algunos electrones
continuamos poniendo estos pares libres
de aquí los electrones en magenta forman
el enlace entre el oxígeno y el carbono
y luego podemos decir que estos
electrones de aquí se movieron a nuestro
oxígeno para darle a ese oxígeno una
carga formal de -1 bien cuando pensamos
en el siguiente paso sabemos que el año
cloruro
es un grupo saliente excelente si estos
electrones en azul se mueven acá para
formar nuevamente nuestro doble enlace
entonces estos electrones se irán al
cloro formando nuestro a neón cloruro el
cual sabemos que es estable por sí mismo
como grupo saliente y entonces eso forma
nuestro anhídrido de ácido continuamos
dibujando la estructura final
tendremos nuestro oxígeno con dos pares
libres de electrones
tendremos este enlace volveremos a
formar nuestro carbón y lo así y luego
el año cloruro fue nuestro grupo
saliente por lo que ahora tenemos
nuestro grupo de reprima así que
formamos nuestro anhídrido de ácido y
podríamos hacer a estos grupos ere los
mismos o podríamos hacer los diferentes
y entonces esta es una buena manera
tanto de formar un anhídrido mixto como
uno simétrico
veamos un ejemplo
tomemos ácido acético y haremos dos
reacciones diferentes con ácido acético
lo primero que haremos es agregar
cloruro de té un hilo al ácido acético
hemos visto que la adición de cloruro de
teo ni lo convierte un ácido
carboxílicos en una luro de asilo así
que continuemos mostrando la conversión
de ese ácido carboxílicos en el allure o
de asilo correspondiente
luego podemos tomar ese ácido acético en
una reacción aparte
podemos agregar hidróxido de sodio
el hidróxido toma a este protón que deja
a estos electrones atrás en el oxígeno
así que movámonos un poco arriba para
que podamos ver el mecanismo del que
hablamos antes esto formaría acetato de
sodio esto formaría acetato de sodio
dibujamos los pares libres de electrones
en este oxígeno la carga formal de -1
a más así este oxígeno ya tenía dos
pares libres de electrones
y ahora tienes esta situación de la que
hablamos aquí arriba tú añón carboxilasa
funciona como un núcleo filo ataca tu
carbono electro físico en tu cloruro de
asilo podemos mostrar a estos electrones
atacando a este carbono
estos electrones se mueven al oxígeno y
luego cuando estos electrones regresan
para formar nuevamente tu doble enlace
estos electrones se mueven al cloro y
entonces podemos continuar dibujando
nuestro producto ciento
pensando simplemente en lo que pasa en
este mecanismo podemos continuar y
dibujar nuestro producto el cual sería
un amigo simétrico tendríamos nuestro
oxígeno aquí y luego tendríamos otro
grupo aquí
por lo que piensa en los grupos se re
esta vez este grupo r es un grupo metido
y luego podemos pensar en este oxígeno
siendo este oxígeno y luego esta porción
de cloruro de asilo es esta porción
de nuestro producto final para el
anhídrido de ácido entonces este es un
año hídrico de ácido este de aquí
un anhídrido de ácido el cual es el que
se usa con más frecuencia en un
laboratorio de universidad y entonces
esta es una buena manera de preparar
anhídridos de ácido bien
y veamos otra manera de formaran
híbridos de ácido
podrías empezar con dos ácidos
carboxílicos cierto este es ácido
acético y este también es el mismo acido
carboxílicos y luego aplicamos calor y
esta vez pensamos en una reacción de
deshidratación podrías pensar en perder
el hd 1 y un hidrógeno del otro
para formar agua podrías pensar en
perder agua aquí en una reacción de
deshidratación y luego puedes juntar
esas dos porciones de la molécula
podrías tomar esta porción y luego esta
porción y ponerlas juntas y ver que eso
es nuevamente anhídrido de ácido así que
continuamos dibujando eso formaremos
anhídrido de ácido aquí por
deshidratación esta manera de hacerlo no
es siempre la mejor manera funciona para
ácido acético pero no funciona para la
mayoría de los ácidos carboxílicos
y aquí hay un caso más que puede
funcionar si tienes una situación como
ésta este es ácido oxálico esto es un
ácido ty carboxílicos y si le aplicas
calor no necesita su calor tan alto como
el anterior este calor es mayor que éste
pero puedes formar nuevamente un
anhídrido si pensamos en una
deshidratación si pensamos en perder un
hd 1 y h del otro y luego podemos
continuar dibujando el producto aquí
formaremos
formaremos nuestro anillo de benceno
formaremos nuestro anhídrido así
nuevamente pérdida de agua
el nombre de este anhídrido de ácido
sería anhídrido ftálico porque viene del
ácido siálico así que esta es una buena
manera de formar anillos de 5 o 6
miembros en este caso tenemos un anillo
de 5 miembros
tenemos un carbono un oxígeno un carbono
un carbono y un carbono por lo que
tenemos un anillo de 5 miembros esta vez
y también funciona para anillo de 6
miembros